Berlin for mr. Toomey Berlin is like
Barcelona it's a multicultural city this
room for everybody the mood on the
streets it feels like home - the weather
but otherwise it's much the same again
eggwin Arriba is the head chef Giovanna
Gonzalez miranda is the host together
they are the creative minds behind the
gastro bar - qua the concept is imported
from Spain small servings made for
sharing any relaxed ambience no she she
just finds Spanish cuisine the gastro
bar and the idea behind it it was like
to do something pretty informal
something like gastronomic like really
haikus in the world where I was working
before but to make it accessible for bit
for people it's kind of democratizing
the Haiku scene so try to do something
like a restaurant but with the
atmosphere of the bar
agar or iguana Riva was born in Spain's
Basque region in 1972 he worked as a
dishwasher to finance his English
studies in Ireland there he acquired a
taste for gastronomy and trained as a
chef he came to Berlin in 2005 here he
gathered experience in a number of fine
restaurants then tip qua gave him free
rein to go wild in the kitchen he bases
his creative experiments on Spanish
Basque culinary tradition I was born in
in a place that is called the arnica and
quite close to the sea when I was child
we were going to the harbor and you were
I was just really amazed by all the
fishermen bring you know the food and
the smell of the fish and then in the
restaurants in the harbor they were used
to cook this this traditional recipe
bacalao our pupil is a traditional dish
from the Basque region bacalao is
Spanish for salted cod the dish calls
for dried and salted fish soaked in
water for two days before it's cooked
that makes it easier to process and
gives it its special taste
you don't need a lot of ingredients for
bacalao a pill pill but you do need
sensitivity and good timing what special
is making mayonnaise from the gelatin of
the fish skin it's produced by slow
cooking making sure that oil doesn't get
too hot the emulsion arising from the
oil and gelatin is called real pill the
dish is a popular delicacy in tip quark
and the recipe has a colorful origin the
fishermen used to go to to cut this cord
to call water and the north and they
used to cut it and part of them they
were put in advance on salt for the
conservation of the of the fish and part
of them they used to put it in the oil
and the movement of the of the boat
actually created this incredible sauce
which is actually just oil and the
gelatin of the fish
Giovanni Gonzales Miranda was born in
Chile in 1983 when he was a youth his
family moved to Barcelona in 2011 he
came to Berlin two years later he and a
river opened the tip qualm
the name is Basque and means Cosa corner
it also refers to when friends come
together to cook and party
[Music]
along with the regular menu tip cooler
has daily specials Giovanni Gonzalez
Miranda acts as sommelier helping guests
choose the right wines
Tipler stocks wines from all over the
world for me wine is more than a drink
it's culture it's the landscape the
earth it's part of a region you don't
know but when you close your eyes you
think yes I know what direction this
comes from it's part of the earth the
two friends found a suitable place for
their gastro bar on a corner in Berlin
smokerin district at first tip car was
only open in the evenings but now it
also offers a lunch menu or cozinha para
vosotros baccala bill bill espero que
vota controversial